using paper notes when the rest of the world moves to digital currency?
Another example from my hometown in Philadelphia:
I recently went to the public library there,
and they are facing an existential crisis.
Public funding is dwindling,
they have to reduce their footprint to stay open and stay relevant,
and so one of the ways they're going about this
is digitizing a number of the books and moving them to the cloud.
This is great for most kids. Right?
You can check out books from home,
you can research on the way to school or from school,
but these are really two big assumptions,
that one, you have access at home,
and two, that you have access to a mobile phone,
and in Philadelphia, many kids do not.
So what does their education experience look like
in the wake of a completely cloud-based library,
what used to be considered such a basic part of education?
How do they stay competitive?
A final example from across the world in East Africa:
there's been a huge movement to digitize land ownership rights,
for a number of reasons.
Migrant communities, older generations dying off,
and ultimately poor record-keeping
have led to conflicts over who owns what.
And so there was a big movement to put all this information online,
to track all the ownership of these plots of land,
put them in the cloud, and give them to the communities.
But actually, the unintended consequence of this
has been that venture capitalists, investors, real estate developers,
have swooped in and they've begun buying up these plots of land
right out from under these communities,
because they have access to the technologies
and the connectivity that makes that possible.
So that's the common thread that connects these examples,
the unintended consequences of the tools and the technologies that we make.
As engineers, as technologists,
we sometimes prefer efficiency over efficacy.
We think more about doing things than the outcomes of what we are doing.
This needs to change.
We have a responsibility to think about the outcomes of the technologies we build,
especially as they increasingly control the world in which we live.
In the late '90s,
there was a big push for ethics in the world of investment and banking.
I think in 2014, we're long overdue for a similar movement
in the area of tech and technology.
So, I just encourage you, as you are all thinking about the next big thing,
as entrepreneurs, as CEOs, as engineers, as makers,
that you think about the unintended consequences
of the things that you're building,
because the real innovation is in finding ways to include everyone.
Thank you.
(Applause)